[Music]
you have an upcoming project it's a it's
coming out it's a movie about the famous
rock club CBGB's right right yeah in New
York and I saw a photograph from this of
the set yeah but look at that this is a
photograph where you're clearly this is
the 70s I guess yeah well late severely
late 70s and I just want to ask I saw
this photograph is the guy on the far
right is that Ron Weasley
yeah yeah Rupert Grint that is him yeah
what happened to Ross ain't heroin i
waxed for that picture oh you yeah you I
do not they took the Jew right out of it
really yeah I like that there's one of
those Lower East Side palm trees too
yeah that's what it was like trees all
over the place you said you've got wax
you got your chest waxed I got it all
wax baby yeah normally I have some hair
on my body and and you know I would have
to go lose some weight on the way to the
gym there was a sign that I pass every
day that was for a waxing place and it
would have you know arms you know chest
back all that stuff and then the last
item was between the cheeks and I was
like I think I'm gonna probably have to
do that so I waited punk rock's the punk
rock singers have no hair I use a real
guy so I knew he had no hair on his body
so I had to do it okay
No I like how you turn to Andy for help
I mean we've all had the between the
Chiefs how does that even work well so
you know you go into this establishment
and they you know you go into this room
with a woman that clearly does this
every you know it's as if people are
shooting the movie Magic Mike everyday
yeah so you know they start you know I
did like my arms my chest and then at
that I was like can I please have the
the between the cheeks and she's like
sure flip over like as if I asked for
you know a piece of gum yeah so it's
like I want an egg McHugh no I figured
they were just wax you know they wax
your ass too you know so they they
actually go between there and they put
wax and there it actually felt kind of
good if I was gonna be honest and know
are you up on your knees no no you're on
your back right you're on your front
with your with you know you're on a
pillow right right but Annie what did
you say you on your knees because that
would be that was your more humiliating
yeah really
if you're gonna really let him get in
there I would think you'd have to be up
on your knees
[Applause]
it's mechanics okay you said it was
enjoyable it did I mean it wasn't you
know it was warm the wax was warm and
then she just goes and she does it and
then she just stops she doesn't do the
rest of the ass and I have to be like
could you and that she thought was weird
as I was sitting there like a hairy
donut and I was like could you do a wrap
[Applause]
[Music]
this is over
this is this is so over